des armoires qui permettent de conduire
la fibre jusqu'au domicile désigné
montrent un constamment dégradé coupure
panne la ville de montigny le bretonneux
et ses habitants n'en peuvent plus
malheureusement nous avons affaire à des
sous traitants qui pour un certain
nombre sont peu scrupuleux ne laisse les
armoires ouvertes des branches un client
pour brancher leur client ne remettent
pas ensuite les
les fils et les branchements tels qu'ils
étaient avant qu'il intervienne début
avril une pétition a été lancée par une
habitante elle compte une vingtaine de
signatures sur le quartier ça fait neuf
fois que comptable est coupée alors il y
en a il y en a où parfois si par
inadvertance d'autres fois c'est
volontaire mais ils vont pas l'admettre
je suis allé voir mes voisins en leur
disant que je pensais écrire à la mairie
il n'y a pas un seul voisin que j'ai vu
qui a refusé de signer la pétition
relevant du domaine privé la ville n'est
pas responsable de ces armoires mais
elle a tout de même souhaité agir suite
multiplication des complaintes une
réunion entre quatre grands opérateurs
et le maire laurin merker a eu lieu le
22 avril dernier face à l'absence de
réponse concrète la municipalité a pris
des mesures j'ai pris la décision de
fermer un certain nombre d'armoires sam
qui était le plus dégradé en installant
un système de cana dessus est dorénavant
il affiche que l'on a apposé sur cette
armoire qui indique à l'opérateur de
sous traitants qui doit se rendre à la
police municipale retirer la clé donné
son identité et la société pour laquelle
il intervient et donc nous lui donnons
la clé il peut intervenir et la rapporte
derrière des solutions qui s'accompagne
d'un engagement de principe des
opérateurs sur la formation et la
responsabilisation de leurs sous
traitants les habitants souvent en
télétravail espère pouvoir profiter de
leur connexion sans désagréments dans le
futur la municipalité restera vigilante
sur le sujet